alors que plusieurs parties de l'europe
sont aux prises avec une canicule que
certaines régions de l'ouest canadien
brûle on observe les conséquences des
changements climatiques face auquel les
dirigeants du monde sont appelés à agir
au canada secteurs du pétrole et du gaz
émet plus du quart de toutes les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre du
pays alors pour verdir le bilan ottawa a
présenté aujourd'hui deux propositions
pour établir un plafond d'émissions de
gaz à effet de serre avec nous steven
guilbeault ministre de l'environnement
et du changement climatique mon soir
monsieur guilbeault bonsoir alors
qu'elles sont expliqués nouvelles
méthodes qui sont à l'étude c'est à dire
le système de plafonnement et la
tarification
effectivement alors l'engagement que
nous avions pris durant la dernière
campagne électorale était de mettre un
plafond sur les émissions de gaz à effet
de serre du secteur du pétrole et du gaz
et ce plafond la évidemment va diminuer
avec le temps pour permettre au canada
d'atteindre les objectifs de 2030
éventuellement 2050 la carboneutralité
de propositions sur lesquelles ont voulu
entendre les différents intervenants
experts groupes écologistes peuple
autochtone entreprises évidemment les
provinces et les territoires donc soit
de mettre en place spécifiquement pour
le secteur du pétrole et du gaz un
système de plafonnement et des changes
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre un
peu comme le fait la californie et le
québec ou encore l'union européenne mais
ce serait spécifique à ce secteur là
pourquoi parce qu'on veut que les
émissions diminuent dans ce secteur là
ou encore d'utiliser la tarification
carbone qui est déjà en application au
canada mais le de l'appliquer
spécifiquement plus spécifiquement le
secteur est de resserrer les règles pour
avoir des réductions d'émissions plus
rapide oui on sait que l'industrie
évidemment s'opposent assez fermement
d'ailleurs à l'idée de plafonner les
émissions part d'aig le mans on peut
s'imaginer qu'il serait plus simple pour
les producteurs d'acheter des crédits
carbone sur une sorte de bourse pour
plutôt que d'assainir leur leurs
activités si on veut mais est ce que ce
serait un peu contraire à l'objectif qui
justement de verdir leur bilan
c'est à dire que s'ils ont décidé de
l'utiliser
le système de plafonnement et des
changes les entreprises ne pourraient
échanger cantrell dans le secteur du
pétrole et du gaz
pourquoi est-ce qu'on le ferait comme
soit comme je le disais plus tôt parce
qu'on veut des réductions d'émissions
dans ce secteur là aux questions leur
permettait de participer à un système de
plafonnement et d'échangé avec d'autres
secteurs pourraient utiliser des
effectivement des crédits d'émission qui
viendraient d'autres secteurs on veut
prévenir cela mais j'aimerais quand même
vous corrigez moi j'ai rencontré
plusieurs représentants de compagnies
pétrolières à quelques reprises qu'ils
m'ont dit nous on veut travailler avec
vous là dessus c'est pas le cas des
provinces notamment la saskatchewan
l'alberta mais les entreprises du moins
c'est là qu'ils mangeaient par les jurys
0 - 2 reprises toutes rencontrées elles
m'ont tous dit ce soit chez elle que ce
soit en cours cenovus nous on veut
travailler avec vous je pense que les
entreprises comprennent que il en va de
leur intérêt dans un monde où nous
allons consommer de moins en moins de
pétrole le pétrole que nous allons
continuer de consommer sur un pétrole
qui va émettre de moins en moins de gaz
à effet de serre alors si les
entreprises ne réduisent pas l'empreinte
écologique est l'empreinte carbone de
leur pétrole je pense qu'il y aura pas
beaucoup de place pour eux dans le
marché que ce soit le marché canadien le
marché mondial bon tant mieux si les
entreprises canadiennes sont optimistes
et favorable face à cette transition par
contre c'est l'échéancier sur lesquels
on se pose des questions 2030 monsieur
guilbeault ça va arriver vite votre
objectif est quand même assez ambitieux
réduire de plus de 30% les émissions du
secteur par rapport à 2005 donc en moins
de sept ans est-ce que c'est réaliste si
on prend en compte le fait qu'il y aura
un processus législatif
une mise en place une possible
contestation est-ce que 2030 aspects
d'abord ce n'est pas la première mesure
que nous mettons en place pour lutter
contre les changements climatiques la
lune alors nous avons depuis 2019 la
tarification carbone qui augmentent à
partir de cette année de 15 $ par année
c'était 10 $ par année en 2030 le canada
l'un des prix sur la pollution les plus
élevés sur la planète nous avons un
règlement sur le méthane qui est un gaz
à effet de serre très puissants pour le
secteur du pétrole et du gaz de réduire
de 40 à 45% d'ici 2025 ces émissions de
méthane nous sommes sur la voie de de
l'atteindre je pense que les signaux
pour l'indutrie sons sont très claires
nous allons en ajouter un autre
évidemment avec avec ça et ce système là
la réglementation sera en place en 2023
même s'il devait y avoir contestation
judiciaire comme ça a été le cas pour la
tarification carbone le système
s'applique est malgré tout est bon nous
avons gagné devant les tribunaux il d'un
point de vue légal nous sommes très
confiants peu importe le système que
nous utiliserons pour le système de
plafonnement que nous sommes sur des
bases légales très solide très bien cela
dit monsieur guilbeault diminuer les
émissions du secteur du pétrole et du
gaz ce serait peut-être un peu plus
facile si on limitait le nombre de
nouveaux projets après b du nord est ce
que c'est terminé l'heure où le
gouvernement du canada va autoriser de
nouvelles exploitations de grandes de
grande envergure
vous parlez de l'imiter
lorsque j'ai accepté le projet des
recommandations de l' agence
d'évaluation environnementale sur le
projet b du nord gip pour la première
fois dans l'histoire du canada refuser
un projet d'expansion de mines de sables
bitumineux aucun ministre de
l'environnement dans l'histoire du
canada qui a dit non à un projet de
sables bitumineux qui aurait mis dix
fois plus de gaz à effet de serre que le
projet de béguinage la réalité peut-être
triste pour certains c'est que même le
giec ou que l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie dit que nous allons encore
consommer du pétrole en 2050 nous en
consommeront beaucoup moins
qu'aujourd'hui nous allons passer de 100
millions de baril par jour là où nous
sommes présentement à quelque part entre
25 et 35 millions de verres pétrole par
jour donc une diminution d'à peu près 75
% oui alors il va rester du pétrole en
2050 dans notre portefeuille énergétique
qui vont rester beaucoup moins et d'un
code du projet du nord ce proche de
l'autre devra être carboneutre en 2050
très bien merci beaucoup pour vos
explications sur guilbeault merci à vous
et bonne soirée pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici
et redit
oh
[Musique]